[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous vous souvenez comment
voyager avant alors quand je dis avant
je vous demande pas de vous rappeler de
votre enfant mais bien d'un temps
lointain qui n'existe plus qui est
révolu
si je vous demande d'imaginer nos
ancêtres voyager il y a 200 300 400 ans
quelle image vous vient en tête
là je pense que vous pensez tous aux
chevaux aux chevaux qui tirent des
calèches des carrosses des chars ou
autres carrioles
effectivement il est difficile
d'imaginer un autre moyen de déplacement
que l'animal le cheval on l'a dit l'âne
éventuellement le chameau pourquoi pas
alors maintenant qu'on a le moyen de
transport de déplacement essayons
d'imaginer la manière dont on voyageait
alors fermez les yeux
imaginez les commerçants les marchands
venus des quatre coins de la France qui
se balade des places de ville en ville
pour vendre le fruit de leur culture de
leur travail
voyage-t-il seul ou en groupe
alors
ah oui
il voyage en groupe à l'époque il est
difficile d'imaginer voyager seul on
craint les attaques de loup on craint
les attaques de brigands ainsi à
plusieurs on se protège on prend soin
les uns des autres
alors qu'en est-il désormais
maintenant que l'industrialisation et
les 30 glorieuses sont passés par là
et bien oui nous avons quasiment tous un
véhicule et la plupart du temps une
voiture
et alors cette voiture on est bien à
l'intérieur de son habitacle on sent
libre on sent en sécurité elle est
rentrée dans notre quotidien
et puis soyons honnêtes elle est souvent
perçue comme le Graal de la liberté
tiens demandez à mon collègue Donovan il
vient d'avoir son permis et sa voiture
s'il n'est pas ravi de ne pas avoir à
temps de le transport pour aller au
travail le matin et le soir pour rentrer
chez lui alors et de savoir qui peut
mettre la musique à fond dans la voiture
voilà le bonheur total
alors voilà encore une personne de plus
qui prend sa voiture toute seule pour
aller travailler alors attention je
jette la pierre à personne moi-même
j'utilise ma voiture
néanmoins nous sommes tous conscients du
besoin de décarboner
nous avons tous entendu parler au moins
une fois de la communauté scientifique
qui parle de réchauffement climatique de
monter des eaux des océans qui
s'assidifient de la biodiversité qui
baisse
et lorsqu'on pose la question à chacun
êtes-vous prêt à agir
la plupart du temps la réponse est oui
et de quoi il subit ce oui
bien trop souvent d'un mais
oui je prendrais bien enfin je
laisserais bien ma voiture au garage
mais faut que j'aille chercher les
petits à l'école ouais je ferais bien du
covoiturage mais si je tombe sur un
bavard qui fait que de parler ou oui je
prendrais bien les transports mais ça
rajoute 30 minutes à mon temps de trajet
et puis la galère du RER B vous
connaissez
des solutions pourtant il en existe
alors elles sont différentes en fonction
de notre lieu d'habitation en métropole
on trouve facilement des métros des
tramways des bus
on trouve également des vélos en
location de l'autopartage
ces solutions en dehors des grandes
agglomérations on les trouve pas ou peu
les lignes de bus sont moindres et leur
régularité de passage pareil
les gars il y en a pas ou peu et elles
sont souvent mal desservies
on peut malgré tout imaginer des
solutions on peut imaginer le
covoiturage entre voisins l'utilisation
du vélo ou l'utilisation des transports
à la demande qui sont mis à disposition
par les communautés de communes
on pourrait même imaginer les employeurs
qui adaptent les horaires de travail en
fonction des transports en commun de la
région
et pourquoi pas ces mêmes employeurs qui
mettraient à disposition des douches
pour leur salarié qui viennent en vélo
alors oui je sais ça peut pas se faire
dans tous les emplois je suis conscient
bref des solutions il en existe
alors pourquoi ne passons nous pas à
l'acte
certainement par habitude dans un
premier temps on le sait il est dur de
lutter contre les habitudes la routine
mais par définition aucun changement ne
peut s'opérer sans bouleversement des
habitudes
et dans notre société profondément
consumériste de quel œil regarde ton
quelqu'un qui ne dispose pas d'un
véhicule
dans un second temps
le temps justement on est sans cesse en
train de courir après ce temps et ce
temps de trajet domicile-travail et
souvent considéré comme une contrainte
comme un temps perdu
ne pouvons-nous pas le bonifier n'est-ce
pas la solution qui nous permettra
d'aller vers une solution de mobilité
durable
alors oui ça demande de détricoter toute
une manière de penser
mais c'est possible j'ai un exemple
j'ai une connaissance qui est en gêne
avait 1h30 de transport pour se rendre à
la fac alors quand on lui demandait à
elle combien de temps elle avait elle
lui dit 10 minutes 10 minutes et ben oui
10 minutes parce que pour elle les 30
premières minutes qu'elle passait en
voiture elle s'informait via sa radio
ensuite elle avait 5 minutes de marche
pour aller à la gare et rejoindre son
train dans son train elle consacrait son
temps à la lecture donc pour elle à la
culture
elle avait de nouveau 5 minutes de
marche dans les couloirs du métro puis
elle marchait encore 20 minutes à
l'extérieur c'est 20 minutes là les
considérer plus facilement comme de
l'exercice physique parce qu'elle était
à l'air libre
donc vous l'avez compris pour elle son
temps de trajet se réduisait aux 10
minutes passées dans la gare ou dans le
métro
alors pour permettre à chacun de
bonifier ce temps d'en tirer des
avantages d'avoir l'impression d'avoir
gagné un temps sur quelque chose nous
avons imaginé une application mobile
cette application
répertoriera l'ensemble des déplacements
de ces membres et leur centre d'intérêt
ainsi quelqu'un ayant peur de prendre
les transports seuls pourra se regrouper
avec d'autres voyageurs pour voyager en
sécurité
ça vous rappellerai
on peut également imaginer que quelqu'un
souhaitant aller au travail en vélo mais
pas motivé à l'idée de le faire seul
pourra trouver un compagnon de route via
cette même application
ce sujet des centres d'intérêt vous
savez peut-être est déjà abordé dans
certaines applications de covoiturage
ainsi on peut voyager avec un fan de
cinéma comme nous et profiter du voyage
pour discuter de notre passion commune
l'idée est de regrouper ça sur
l'ensemble des solutions de mobilité
durable
je veux apprendre l'anglais je peux
peut-être voyager avec un anglophone et
profiter du temps du trajet pour
apprendre sa langue
le but est simple retrouver cette bulle
que l'on a à l'intérieur de notre
habitacle et la mettre dans un autre
type de transport ou alors de la faire
partager lors d'un covoiturage alors
encore une fois repensons notre
quotidien quelles sont nos habitudes
la moyenne de la distance
du trajet domicile-travail depuis 2019 a
augmenté on est passé de 14 à 16 km
on peut imaginer que ainsi qu'on est
plus mobile ma paradoxalement on n'a
jamais été autant assis
donc réintroduisons la marche et le vélo
de manière plus forte dans notre
quotidien ça peut être que bon pour
notre santé aussi
alors ça peut paraître contraignant mais
je vous jure on y trouve tous un
bénéfice
je ne vous dis pas de laisser la voiture
au garage au quotidien on en aura
toujours besoin j'en suis bien conscient
mais néanmoins si on peut réduire son
usage ne serait-ce qu'un peu on aura
déjà fait un premier pas parce que
finalement ce temps après lequel on
court sans cesse
ce temps que l'on souhaite gagner tout
le temps sur quelque chose il y a
peut-être une chose qui n'a plus le
temps devant elle c'est la nature
alors on peut vivre comme bon nous
semble mais une chose est sûre c'est que
sans la nature on ne vivra pas bien
longtemps
alors cette application va nous
permettre de nous retrouver de recréer
du lien de pouvoir voyager à plusieurs
comme nos ancêtres pour réduire
l'auto-solisme et pour bonifier ce temps
que le considère souvent comme du temps
perdu alors pour soi pour les autres
pour la nature mettons à profit notre
trajet pour faire ce qu'il nous plaît
merci
[Applaudissements]